Last time, um, I
finished, uh, we finished,
we're not on a little note
as you recall, that, uh,
the detail of the garden where the
pilgrims finds himself and meet the,
the other,
we have a poet and he declares in a
way that seems to be really prideful,
uh,
on his place in this trajectory,
this literary, uh, poetic
tradition. And, um,
I was emphasizing God's timing.
This is a detailed that opens, uh,
for us,
uh,
opens her eyes to the
ambiguity of gardens,
the ambiguity as Dante world go on,
dramatizing this idea of this
ambiguity of gardens throughout,
uh, purgatorio specialty and then
at a other areas in, in, in, in,
in oblique ways,
not necessarily monotonously
a bucolic language.
Uh, this idea of the,
the ambiguity of gardens.
What are some of these abuses
and can't have for, uh,
we are drawn naturally to gardens.
Uh,
and we are drawn to gardens
because they reflect for us, uh,
some he verge of, of the, especially
if you're traveling through hell,
then you do want this sort
of, uh, you, you explore,
you enter willfully this place that bears
the finger prints of the human hand.
Uh, it's something which had
been elaborated by human beings.
This is a divine place and
unless gardens mean that for us,
but at the same time they,
they give us a sense of security and in
its enclosure also sense of our lordship
over them. You know, it's
something we can control.
It's something that we see and uh,
and, and, and where we feel we belong.
This is exactly the temptation that
the pilgrim experiences in Canto for.
He relaxes. And this happens to all
heroes in epic to the epic tradition.
When they enter gardens, they
even, uh, set aside their arms.
They get these armed
in more ways than one.
That is to say they come to understand
that they are, this is a place of shelter,
a place which is so peaceful and idyllic.
That one is no longer or need
not feel that one is in danger.
In effect.
That's where the danger is most powerful.
Dante experiences a danger,
the danger he experiences
that have a poetic Hubris.
He is descending into humility.
That's the trajectory of his journey.
And there he rests with
Houma, Virgil, Lucan,
et cetera.
And he just says he feels that he belongs,
that his hi genius allows him
to be right there with them.
I remind you of this little detail
exactly what say that it allows me to say
more precisely, uh, what,
what the problems are the
representation of gardens,
but especially to emphasize that can't
have five and the drama that is unfolded
in Canto Five,
a drama ostensibly of desire.
It's a story of, uh, the
great passion of a woman.
One of the most famous women in
literature, uh, uh, Francesca, uh,
has with her in brother-in-law bowel.
But the point is that that drama stems
directly from the crisis in the pilgrims
mind. In Canto four of
inferno. In what way?
It is as if the experience of Hubris
about the celebrating one's home power and
prowess is a port now his to confront
the consequences of that claim.
Now Dante comes literally face to face
with a reader of his poetry and the
reader reads poetry who understands
his poetry in a way that that was not
necessarily the one
intended by its author.
We have now in Canto five
the confrontation of reader
and port and we just did
for Francesca is of course,
as you remember from your
reading, just having, having,
having read Canto five is
a great reader of texts.
She goes home port in glance a lot,
not,
not in the version of critiquing
the Torah, but it's, it's,
it's a parallel version. Uh, the
assistance, the same bromance.
Uh, she goes home quoting
from the art of courtly love,
this text about the art of love by,
and there's Capilano's a,
you may remember,
I,
I alluded to at least in one of the
earlier talks and goes on actually quoting
to Dante,
Dante's own toy him in the Vietnam war
that we should go and root cat in a,
in a while. So, uh, let's start with
Canto five. Where are we in the port?
What, what, where are we located?
We are in the second circle.
This your notes will tell you will in the
larger area of so called incontinence.
And I really should emphasize
to you something about that.
We should look at it the more
it more detail further on,
but something about the topography,
the moral topography of hair.
What is the disposition?
So what is the distribution
of sins and sinfulness?
What is actually a sin?
But what,
what are we to understand
for sale for the time being?
I'll tell you that for Dante, it's
the will, which is the locals of sin.
You cannot really seen intellectually,
you cannot have commit
since with your mind.
You can have your mind which partakes
and becomes an accomplice of the wheel,
but it's primarily in the
will in the, the, the,
the voluntary action that you
find. Uh, you find sinfulness.
That's the first thing. But what are
we now in the area of incontinence? Uh,
what does that mean? Well, one thing,
a way of making it very simple,
you probably should know that the,
um,
that the,
the shape,
the diagram of the soul for Dante
is Mary classical, very ancient.
It's really, uh, Aristotelian,
it's the idea of,
it's more or less figured as a triangle.
Uh,
uh,
which with on the left side you have,
because it's always the left,
the wheel, the area of the wheel.
And then on the right side you
have the area of reason. Okay.
Where the tool, faculties of
the soul, there are two factors,
like two feet of the body. Uh,
the two faculties of the soul,
uh, where they lead. It's in the
middle ages using a classical term,
the call sin. They're
assessed as to say, yeah,
this is the other of free will
in order to have free will.
You have a conjunction
of both will a reason.
And that's the beginning of the moral
life. It's not the end of it at all.
It's really when, not only when
you're really free, we will is free.
Then you can start making decisions, are
getting engaged in the world around you.
Now the soul is divided into three parts,
is a tripartite structure,
and begins at the bottom. It's so
cold. I should put it on the side.
Will the [inaudible] percent appetite,
which is really what Francesca
experiences, you know, the, the, the, uh,
in continents, uh, lost in this
form later we'll be gluttony,
et cetera. Uh, average is per
the gallery in the middle area.
Here you would have
the sensitive appetite,
which is really the middle ground
of Dante's hell, uh, violence,
uh, uh, the kind of beastiality,
uh, that takes over the,
the, the human mind. And then the
third is the rational. Okay? So, uh,
the older, the geometry of hair, uh,
in a way,
his pattern on the older of the soul,
the idea of this all in, of course,
in an inverted, inverted form,
we begin within the area of concupiscence,
the area of lust.
Someone was asking me what it was last,
last drive.
I think that we're going to have,
uh,
some kind of understanding a partner.
So this is where we are in
the aid of incontinence.
The first one is it's lost over,
Dante would call in with a formula.
It's the area of the sinners
who have inverted the,
the older,
the hierarchical order of
the reason and the will,
they have made pleasure, uh, the,
they have invested pressure with Supreme
Lordship over the older of rationality.
So, uh, recently somehow them,
or it's going to be used as a rationale
to explain as a kind of way of,
uh, creating alibis
for the passion of, uh,
of, of Francesca. So this is, uh,
this is the way the Canto begins. Um, the,
uh, the second thing that I, I have
to mention as we read here is, um,
the particular, uh,
landscape that Dante evokes.
It's a landscape of souls go around,
swirling around in,
in a kind and sort of a circular,
circular structure.
And let me tell you a little detail here
that you have to be careful as you read
the poem, even about the directions
of the pilgrim. Uh, for instance,
if I were to ask you, which is Dante
descending into a spiral of hair,
uh,
and then we'll move into a spiral.
It's very difficult if you're really
going left or right, of course, but he's,
he goes out of the way to say that he's
always going left word leftward because
it's descending and as soon
as we get to purgatorial,
he goes out of their way to tell
us that he's now going right word,
which is to say that hell
is the inverted cosmo.
So purgatorial. So it's really, he's
always going the same way. Only that is,
it goes into hell. It's going
down and his, his inverted,
when he has to go from
health to Purgatorio,
the operation is going to be that of
turning upside down in order to go finally
in the straight way, the right way. Uh,
the other detail is that the,
the, the symbolism of the circle,
which is, you know, is
very ancient, very old.
There are a number of ways of
understanding direction in, uh,
in the Middle Ages.
For instance,
the linear direction implies that of
human beings who are caught in time and
they are going to some kind of
purpose of precise destination.
The angels are those who circled
around the throne of God,
so that the circle implies the
plenitude and perfection of movement.
Clearly Francesca is involved,
uh,
who is called in in a world of
love and the passion of love.
She's giving a kind of parotic version,
a caricature of a,
of the circular perfect
movements of the mind. Uh, and,
and of the angels around the,
around the, uh, the, the, the,
the divinity, uh, the spiral,
which is the movement of
the pilgrim combines line.
And circle implies that Dante is really,
the mind is going in a circular way
around the divinity, but he's also has,
has a purpose as an Ame, uh, to reach.
So here the two, uh, uh,
Francesco and Paolo are going around
in circles circles that we'll have and
their work experience. No
rest. I think that the,
the principle behind this representation
of a desire as displacement is idea is
always a potter's presence.
Something that valorizes greatly.
That's the ambiguity of Dante's
thinking. Uh, uh, desire is displacement.
So in this case, powdered
Francesca, they get nowhere.
And yet it's exactly this displacement
that makes us aware that we are never,
what do we should be,
that our hearts at all is out of place.
It's what our Gustin says
in the confession that the,
he begins the confessions with the
awareness stuff. His heart, he says, uh,
is, is, uh, I'm quiet. You know,
that the idea of the quietness
of the heart out of place.
So that's what he's enacting, not
this moving within the larger, um,
pattern of Guston's thinking
about, uh, about desire.
Uh, and there'll be a
lot of talk about, say,
you know what the word desire by the way,
which is it English as the same as,
as it's an Italian or, or in Latin, you
know what it means. It's, it's, it's,
it's linked to the stars, you know, to,
to have desire is to know that
you are not, uh, quite, uh, uh,
see that, uh, at the end
they see that, uh, you know,
we are so two very movable removed
from the, the, the, the world of, uh,
of stars. Uh, uh, it's, it's, uh,
it's, it's a word that is linked,
usually is consideration.
In other words,
that implies that the mind
moves alongside, you know,
who you consider when I consider her.
My light spent when you consider is,
is a way of moving with a along the mind
managers to move with the circularity
imperfection on the side.
All of this is irrelevant to the
point that it's at hand here.
Uh, [inaudible] meets a, so we are
in the world of begins is, uh, this,
this candle with a number
of, um, a number of,
uh, metaphors of, of birds. You,
you realize that first of all,
he starts at online's 30 about
the hellish storm. It's, no, it's,
it's, it's the externalizing of, of, uh,
the storm inside the,
the in the storm never resting,
seizes and drives the spirits before.
It's my thing,
a world in them about et
cetera. It continues. Uh,
and this in the cold
season, the wings bear, uh,
the starlings along the broadens
flock. So does the blast, the blast,
that wicked spirits hitter
data downward upward.
It drives them no hope if a
conference and not to say of rest,
but have less pain. And then
the cranes and Dante asks, uh,
Virgil Master,
who are these people that black hair,
so scorchers and now have an
enumeration and other, uh,
application of the epic epic,
an epic device,
enumerating the epic,
uh, that, that, that has,
it's always driven by the desire for
totality to include all things within the
commpass of its representation.
Always says, uh,
this enumerative style.
And now here we have a number of figures
that Dante points are that the virtual
points out and then all
queens at the beginning,
queens of founders of cities.
Keep this in mind.
It was a thing, a part of the
issues that Dante is raising.
And you can think about it,
we can talk about it if you wish,
is the relationship with an airbrush
and politics are pleasure and the city.
Where does,
where does pleasure,
what is the place of pleasure
in the economy of the city?
Man.
W W W W let's see who they are.
One is the empress of people
of many tongues who so
corrupted by licentious vice
that she made lust lawful in hello to
take away the scanned on who she was
brought and the, and the, and the,
and the emphasis of the lioness.
This lust becoming lawful last,
becoming a public and, and,
and, and, and accepted.
And she's Semiramis of Syria, uh,
whom within the success niners.
Uh, uh, then, uh, the
next one is dido. Who is,
uh,
both Virgil invention in many ways.
We're,
we're Virgil in the AENEID.
This is a reflection on the hernia.
There's a poem of love
to, you know, the, the uh,
can unknown, but think
about the, the place of, uh,
how Rome Rome's conquest,
uh,
could appear to be libido of power,
Libido Dominandi and yet,
and he's really playing with
the idea that the, uh, uh,
Rome of Roma as you know,
is the,
what we call the have to use this term.
It was, I can't think of an English term,
uh, boost referred on. You know, what
it needs that boost profit on, right?
It was proffered on,
it's an easy,
it's the Greek term meaning a reversal,
a Roma,
right as in a mirror
becomes arm or you know,
it's Venus is the mother of an years.
So there is this idea again of a link
in the link between love or a love and,
and politics in the city.
And Virgil writes there near the,
literally as a love poem,
Mr Say,
the ideology of Rome is
an ideology or based on,
on of Rome is an ideology based on desire.
The which Augustan will counter by saying,
yeah,
this is not really love.
This is lust for power.
And the distinction that
someone was raising here, uh,
the gentleman was raising last time
about how his lost related to love.
You already start seeing the antagonism
between the two of them are Gustin I
Roman, uh, an African,
but a Roman Roman thinker,
uh, is really writing about and belongs
and reflect on the great myths and the
mythology of Rome.
And to him this is true in the,
but it's especially true in the city of
God where he just does juxtaposes the
earthly state, they roam to the
heavenly city, the heavenly Jerusalem,
the two cities are opposed to each other.
They're,
he reflects or Rome as a
city based on lust for power.
And from that point of view,
really not different from any other
empires that are all Rome or like car,
say the Persian empire,
the Greek claims for empire and whatnot
are all part where long Cifo of,
uh, of uh, violence and uh, uh,
imperial imperial fantasies.
So Dante is,
is,
is thinking along along these lines and
we shall see where that will take him in
a moment.
Then that is Cleopatra's Egypt.
Allan and the story of the
four of uh, of, of Troy.
And then finally, the story of
Tristan, who as you know, belongs,
is really a medieval medieval inventure
Tristan and these old we are going to
see now Lancelotta Guinevere
in a moment. So, uh,
the presence of Tristan shows one thing
that all the heroes and heroines of
antiquity are viewed through
the lenses of medieval romances.
They may belong to the grand epics
of classes, the classical world.
Dante will see them through that.
Optics of a romance is
the literature of Desire.
And she showed me more than a thousand
shades named them as he pointed.
This is the, the, the, the, the
catalog of the epic catalog. Welcome,
love parted from our life.
When I heard my teacher named the
Knights and ladies of old times,
pity came upon me and that
was as one big wilderness.
Now,
this is really the first time that Dante
introduces the notion of pity in the
poem and we shall see by the end of the,
of the cancer that is going
to be overwhelmed by Peter
and he's going to faint
after he hears the story of Francesca.
You're so overwhelmed that he fell.
He says like a dead body falls.
It's a feigned tickets. It's, it's,
it's sympathy. Maybe it's a little
bit of a self recognition. Maybe it's,
we shall see that it's a way of coming
to grips with his own responsibilities.
Maybe,
maybe some of his responsibilities.
But the point I want to make there with
this pity is that you do know that he
does not know the RPA.
The poetics of our store too,
or he knows whatever is
available are through Horace.
And he knows it's quite
a lot. Uh, the, the,
the point here is that Dante goes over,
reflects,
they commit a paper topic for
some of you enterprising spirit.
Some of you may be on the
relationship between pity and justice.
How throughout the poem he goes on
thinking about this two terms is that's
justice necessarily.
Need pity or is there some kind of justice
that must learn how to be ptls that
has no place for,
for this kind of compassion or the two
necessarily antagonistic or is there some
way of, of, of thinking
of, of uh, of a meeting,
a meeting point between them? This is
the first time he introduces this, uh,
this idea of pity kind of recognition.
So to have a sense that it could
be he who is in that, that,
that position and he begins poet.
I would feign speak with this tool that
go together and seem so light upon the
wind.
So he doesn't talk to any of the major
classical figures he chooses to people
from his own time. Two
people from the ordinary, uh,
life around him to people in the dust.
By this time,
Dante may very well be
living in that area of Italy,
which is Ravenna, not quite
Ravenna, but in that area or oven,
the shall see when they are
near us and that intrigued them.
Then by the love that leads them.
And they will come as soon as
the wind band or weirded sold,
come and speak to us and speak with us.
If one four bids it not,
you realize that the name of God is
never mentioned here in hell. If not,
uh, as a, as a discourse that
takes place here on earth.
But the souls in hell,
we'll all use,
always use paraphrased
stick constructions.
Turns of phrases as if it would be,
it would be highly improper or for Dante
to allow them or driven for them to
acknowledge that which they never really
acknowledged. Now if it's one, four bids,
it not, and then as dove someone
but desire are come with wings.
Pose the motion for the sweetness
born by the wheel through the air.
So this lift, the trooper dido
is again the presence of Dido,
uh, that, that the Virgilian,
the Virgilian myth of Dido.
Um,
and also the other possibility of Rome,
uh,
virtual is writing about the,
the great battle between Carthage
and Rome is two ways of choosing the
civilization to ways of,
of deciding how one should organize.
One I should want to experiment
with, uh, with, with cities. Uh, um,
so coming to us through the
malignant hair, such force, uh,
had my loving core,
uh,
and now listen to how Francesca
speech or living creature,
gracious and friendly, who goes
through the murky air visiting us,
who stay in the world with blood. She's
killed. She was killed by the way,
but her husband who caught Francesca
and his brother Paolo in a trust.
So it's, so that's what the
illusion to the blood is.
If the king of the universe where our
friend would pray to for the piece,
since the has pity over
evil plight of work,
which are pleased to hear and
speak here and speak with you,
what the wind is quiet and here it is,
and how she begins the description
of her life when she was born.
Most of the narratives in, in, in,
in fentanyl begin with this idea of birth,
your soul,
that in the case of Virgil and you see her
once again here in the case of, uh, of,
uh, in the case of Francesca
and the begin with birth, uh,
for a number of reasons, but
because birth is for Dante, the,
that event that somehow could potentially
have changed and they've imparted the
different direction to the
world. All could. And, uh,
and nothing is in the case
of Francesca insights,
very a great piece of literature, but she
of herself, uh, did not worry, achieve,
achieve much.
And now she talks about her city in
terms of clear the contrast with this
movement of the souls caught in the storm.
There they go endlessly, uh, in the air.
And now she evokes the place of what
she really wants is, is, is, is rest.
The city where I was born lies emerge
of a stability of a city she has lost
where the pole with the streams
are jointed, descend to rest.
And now three tercets in Italian,
all beginning with the word love,
love made into kind of
transcendent divinity.
It is the great subject of,
uh,
of her experience. Look at this love, um,
love which quick is quickly kindled.
And the gentle heart sees this man for
the fair form that was taken from me and
the manner afflicts Mr. Love,
which absorbs no one beloved from loving
sees me so strongly with this charm.
This RCS does not leave me yet.
Love brought us to one
death when she saying, well,
a number of things and that will have
to give this to you. First of all,
she's really quoting, uh, important
literature. The first line,
uh, love which, uh, uh, uh,
it's translational is love,
uh, which absorbs known love,
which is quickly kindled
in the gentle heart.
And you know that this is really a
quotation from one of Dante's Sonnets,
the Vita Nuova that you
read, Chapter 20. Love,
that's her Dante starts.
And the gracious heart are a single
thing is Dante quotes the poetics of the
sweet new salaries when need, certainly
he says, tells us in his poem,
one can more be without the other one
can no more be without the other then one
that then can the reasoning mind
without its reasons et cetera. So, uh,
it's,
it's clearly meant for Francesca to
flatter the sense of
authorship of the poet himself.
It's part of a seductive strategy also
that she could use the second image that
about love that uh,
does not allow anyone who loves from
returning reciprocating the love.
It really comes from the so called rules
of love that Meridian Shampine dictates
in book three of the art of courtly
love. And I want to read this. Uh,
it's, the translation is not quite
all that accurate, but I think,
uh, I'm sorry I get the wrong one.
The wrong book. The Art of culture.
He loved the book three and these are the
famous, it ends with the rules of love.
I will, I will, I'll explain what
they are. And rule nine says it,
I can really read some of them to use so
they have an understanding of what real
love is it this is the mind of which
applies very well to Francesca.
Francesca imagines herself
is really a quarterly, uh,
love heroin.
She lives in the world of a king.
God is the king of the universe, is in
the court of the King of love. May Be,
and these are some of the,
the, the concerns of the, the,
the rules of love and they are
difficult to love marriages.
No real excuse for not loving.
It's a way of saying adultery is the law.
Of course we love.
He who is not jealous.
Number two cannot love.
No one can be bound by a double
love and then they come home.
Boys do not love until they
arrive at the age of maturity.
It leaves that very unclear what
the age of maturity can be. Seven,
when one lover dies and we'd hold of
two years is required of the survivor.
Number eight, no one should be deprived
of love with at the very best of reasons.
Number nine,
no one can love a less one is
impelled by somebody else's love,
which is exactly the line that
Francesca mentions. Number nine,
why this rules of love and what are they
and what is she saying where Andre has
first of all this oil by having this rules
of love and having a reducing love to
or not,
it's a way of acknowledging that love
is the most transgressive disruptive of
all experiences and therefore
it needs to be formalized.
It needs to be contained,
made, may be part of a game,
isn't perhaps is the thrust of undress
Capilano's thinking or made to be part of
an acceptable ceremony, which is the other
possible reading of what is happening.
Francesca false s completely,
uh,
squarely within this
tradition of believing that
she lived in a world of love
where there is no other
possible resistance in effect,
these three persons with which, which
I read to you about love La, I love,
they're really meant to cast love as
a transcendent force that no one can
really, uh, she at least cannot withstand.
What she's doing is advocating
the power of her will tool,
the irresistible, omnipotent,
uh, presence of this love.
It's part of a strategy, none of
acknowledging and the responsibility,
it's part of its strategy to
instead find for herself an alibi.
I was made to do that.
The literature of yours and the literature
of Andrea [inaudible] work filters of
love. You understand what I mean? How in
romances you always have filters of love.
No one is going to take the
responsibility. It's like,
well, uh, you know, the,
uh, I had too much to drink or
I read a great poem or whatever.
And so I was doing that.
It's a way for Dante to show the,
the blindness of Francesca to the reality
of her situation and this where she is
a kind of willingness to give up that
which is really the quality of sin and the
trait of sin. Habit. Sin
Is sin and the measuring,
which it has become a habit,
a way of,
a way of clinging to it
and not acknowledging that
there may be some kind of
alternative or something
different, uh, to it.
So Dante goes on now enter entertaining
the arguments when answer to be an alas,
how many sweet thoughts, great desire
brought them to the wolf house.
And then Francesca that torments,
make me weep for grief and pity.
Pat Tell in the time we switched time,
how and what occasion did love grandchild
to know you're uncertain desires.
And she answered,
there is no greater pain than to recall
the hippie time and misery and this
strategic a teacher knows.
But if that has so great desire
to know our loves first route,
which is a way of almost even
that metaphor of the root of love,
the origin of love,
she calls it the root of love,
as if the passion,
her passion with the flower of,
of love.
Uh,
I shall tell as well as one
way that we've in talent.
We read one day for the past time of
Lancelot have constrained him where alone
and had no misgivings many times that
reading through our eyes together and
change the color in our faces.
But one point alone,
it was that mastered us when we read
for the long for smile was kissed by so
great a lover. He who never shall
be parted from me or trembling,
kiss my mouth a gully Aalto was a
book and he that wrote it that day.
We read in it no farther while
the one spirit said this,
the other Paolo whose name
means little Latin as you know,
palace small web.
So that for PT,
as soon as if in death and
joked dropped like a dead body,
and that's the end of the camp
where we could say it's, it's uh,
it's an amazing a story undoubtedly would,
we will talk about a number of things.
The first thing he is, uh, uh, that
this is a scene represented through,
um, uh, reading the
story of reading. Yeah.
You're aware of that, right? This
is clearly, uh, she reads the reads,
it says that we're one day
they were reading for delight.
That's probably part of, um, the, the,
the concerns that Dante has. How
should we read? If we read for Delight,
they read for delight. Uh, is there some
other way of reading? Uh, it's delight.
Clearly it's, it's, it's the constitutive
elements of reading literary texts.
But is there something else
that we could do along the way?
What is her problem really that's
continued with this idea of reading.
She's reading the story of
Lancelot Lancelot and Guinevere.
You do know the stories,
especially if you could re it's not,
it's not the story of creating the
club or you could easily go on. Uh,
if you want to write about creating the
Trois Lancelot and camp of five, you can,
Dante does refer to the
stories of critique that
floor often in his theoretical
works, uh, the story of a landfill,
the story of adulterated court Lancelot
is the secret lover of the Queen,
clearly out of the desire.
And that says something about the nature
of desire to really supplant the king.
Arthur. They said, triangle.
Here it stay a triangle
of desire. Uh, and, and,
and Francesca imitates his triangle.
I will talk to about it in a moment.
Lancelin story of Lance Hill
to the story of, uh, uh,
let me go a little bit a bit into that.
It's the story of like all the stories of,
and they try,
they begin on the great
feasts of Christianity.
It's, I think it's usually the
ascension, uh, Easter Pentecost,
one of the great feasts,
and the heroes are sitting
around boasting about themselves.
No one of them, uh, is
doing anything heroic,
but they will talk about
how great they were.
It's a little bit like the periodic
version that you have of the battle of the
argument between Ulysses and a,
and Ajax in the last is the last book of
the metamorphosis where they talk about
who is the, the, the, the,
the hero worthy of inheriting
the arms of the Great Achilles.
And they talk about not
the present prowess now,
but what they were in the
story of, in criterion. Uh,
clearly the idea is that the
heroic age is over and done with,
and the whole romance goes on exploring,
pondering about that,
which the reasons why the heroic age
may have come to an end. And what it is,
is that,
uh,
the secret love affair between
Lancelot and Guinevere,
the stories, thoughts,
it goes on, what are,
they are sitting around
drinking and talking.
A mysterious figure comes from
the outside and kidnaps the queen.
Then the knights who were sitting around
don't move and everybody's expecting
Lancelot to get up and
go and rescue the queen.
But he won't out of fear that if you
were to impetuous, it would be this, the,
the secret affair that he has with the
Queen would probably be be discovered.
That hesitation,
that moral hesitation of Lancelot is
really the cause of it is it's the emblem
of the falling from any store cratic
virtues that is now the intrusion of it at
time. A temporal wedge between
the thought and the action.
And then of course lance would have to
go and their famous cart of shame exposed
to the ridicule of the whole town before
he can go on really trying to rescue,
uh, the, the, the queen. So this
is that. If you think about it,
then the PTN is already reflecting
on the crisis of the city.
In terms of the private passions.
Something is really knowing at the heart.
Is it the end?
It's really the question of desire,
the inability to distinguish between the
public and the private Nina ability to
separate somehow the two or find
some sort of a harm threading the,
the, the, the line between
those two concerns. He can five.
This is really what Francesca does.
Dante's exploring reading.
So she is reading the texts of Lancelot
and lapses into an imitative strategy of
reading. She wants to be like
the heroin that she reads about.
She refuses to take an interpretive
distance from whatever specular emerge.
She wants to feel like a queen.
And she thinks that Paolo can be like
Lancelot. And this is exactly what,
what we call the mimetic quality. It's
not my term, it's the term of uh, uh,
uh, [inaudible] who has written about this
question of the imitative structure of
desire between us and
the object of desire.
There is always the presence of a
mediator. And this time. In this case,
the mediator is Lancelot for,
uh,
for Paolo entities
Guinevere for Francesca.
But there's is more to this story.
For instance,
you can not read this story without
thinking about how don t frames the
experience of Francesca
with the language of time.
Can you see how many references
there are two time, uh,
there is no greater grieve
that remembering happiness,
the past happiness.
And this your doctor meaning meaning,
uh,
Virgil knows very well.
And then she starts talking about her
adventure. We were reading one day.
You remember that day we read no further.
It's soul about time.
About the question of
time as if an experience.
So what is the problem with this idea
of time? Why is Francesca understood?
Why is has story represented
in terms of time? In effect,
I think Francesca want,
there's one great passion though she
has and her passion is to do away with
time.
She's expressing the desire,
the happiness that lasts year.
Very briefly.
Brief instance may really
last an eternity, or maybe,
or maybe just maybe she
makes pressing the wish that,
or the idea,
the insight more than the wish that one
moment of happiness is well worth an
eternity of pain.
Or maybe she's just saying
that it's not too bad.
That the love story I had only
lasted the briefest possible time.
At any rate or all this shows is that
primarily Francesca nor only up dedicated
choice and not only thought that
her own wheel was powerless,
visa vi the resistible force of this
transcendent idea of love, but above all,
she's betrayed.
The less,
the older of necessity end time that
her passion violates the order of time.
And the Bravo from this point of view,
Dante goes all reflecting
about his responsibilities
of an author as an author,
uh, when he's confronted with
the reader, what have I done?
What have I written?
That what I write has been understood
in a way that is not necessarily the one
that he meant.
Uh,
the meaning that he meant
to assign to the Vita Nuova.
So these are some of the concerns
and we can find some others.
Let me just pass on to Canto six,
which is really not a completely unlike
what we have been describing here.
Now we go into Kent Dante goals.
That's another part of
this other strategy.
Whatever Dante's found out about passion,
about desire,
about this in the world of appetites
are and whatever he has decided about
himself and the meaning of this may
have for him as a port in that scene of
fainting at the end who will go on.
This will become the premise for
other concerns raised in Canto six,
which is, you know, is a
political candidate. But this
is the strategy of Dante.
Let me see. I found out certain
things about me, my responsibility.
I found some things about the,
the disruptive quality of a desire
visa vi the political order.
Now let me find out. Let
me see. Uh, if, if, uh,
let me find out how our
authentic this finding may be.
Let me move into a public room.
So we go from the world of the court,
the private world of Francesca now
to literally the world of the city,
the world of Florence,
where we are still talking about
incontinence in a different form.
The question of Gluttony,
gluttony and uh,
politics and let's see.
So he takes elements that he has
already anticipated here in Canto five,
the political and goes on thinking
about politics in, in Canto,
in Canto six. Ah, here we
go. Then with Canto six,
the third circle, uh, the gluttonous
with the return of my mind,
that was shut off when the Pto
state of the two kings fork,
which was quite confounded me with grief,
new torments and new soul's in torment.
I see about me,
whatever I move and turn and set my gaze.
I find first of all,
the,
the presence of the word mind in
Italian is maintain a Lineman,
a very, very, very suggestive.
We are dealing here now with bodies.
Canto six is all about bodies.
It's all about gluttonous souls where
bodies who took care of the bodies.
But Dante uses as a counterpoint
the question of mind as if,
uh,
the scene of this body's the scene of
this gluttonous has also been the scene of
not thinking in terms of mind.
Their mind is unnecessary counter and
necessary compliment to the presence of
bodies. They weren't mine
of course, as you know,
or an Italian in English where
mentor in Italian is meant a lot.
It meant really comes from
the Latin for measure. Uh,
the mind is that which measures things
that nine is that which gives a sense of
the measure of our, even our own, our
own desires and the, and the, and the,
and the metaphor of mind appears
throughout Canto six. Uh,
we are asked to think of that which is
missing in this biological or reflection
or reflection about the,
what I called the biology of politics.
Politics now reduced to the
question of appetites of bodies.
And it's not normally we have the pride
of minds when we think about, you know,
all the people who have whatever
fantasies, whatever Megalomania is,
whatever desires. But mental above
all where we talk about politics.
But here it's,
it's really a question of politics in
terms of the inexhaustible appetites of
bodies are.
And so we are going to talk about
politics and a and gluttony politics and
borders. Dante here meets
the figure that is presiding.
The mythological figure that is presiding
over cantos of this area of gluttony
is a, um, the classical figure
of the three headed, uh,
servers at way of hinting about the,
uh,
the voraciousness Ah, uh, the
many miles of this, uh, this, uh,
monsters animal servers, a beast,
fierce and hideous and so on.
Um,
and we do know that the landscape
is stinking and that the,
an endless rain, uh, there
are hints that this is really,
uh, uh, one of, uh,
some kind of repulsive a
form of a waste and food. Uh,
it's at the rain makes him how like
dogs and the Profane wretches, uh,
uh, often turned themselves a one
side making a shelter for the other.
When servers,
the Greek warm perceived us.
He opened his mouth and
showed us the fangs,
not one of his limbs keeping steel in
my leader and so on as the dog that Yelp
to greed and becomes quiet when it bites.
It's food being all absorbed
and struggling to devour
and such became this fall
vintages of the demon servers.
Uh,
we passed up the shades that were beaten
down by the heavy rain setting of feet
on the emptiness, which seemed
real bodies. Uh, this is,
uh,
the,
the great description and
figuration of Gluttony, uh,
bodies that are always
empty and the, the, the, uh,
and the are empty now,
punished to be empty as empty forms
and that they seem they're not bodies.
They seem real bodies that were all lying
on the ground except one who set up as
soon as he saw us passing before him
or thou who are led through this hell.
He said to me,
recall if thou canst thou was begun
before I was ended and other little
reference to birth,
the birth of Dante and the death
of that is part of a cycle.
No, there's no necessary
connection between the two
events. That death of a, uh,
the name is Jack,
come in and get pig.
That's the way he was sort of named
in the streets of Florence and a,
the death and the birth of the
pilgrim. I said to him, the anguish,
the anguish style perhaps takes the,
from my memory and when the
word is mentor the mind,
so I'll not seem ever to have seen the
Tommy who you are put in a place of such
misery and the such a penalty that
fan is greater nannies, wholesome.
And he said to me,
thy city talking about Florence,
this is the politics of the city.
They city and doesn't say,
I city your city.
So He's already,
he chuck who views
himself as outside of it,
not really occupying a
place within the city,
which is so full of envy there already.
The sac around solver helped me within
it in the bright light when you citizens,
once again a distance of
chuck of from the the,
the city of Florence called me Chaco
for the damning full to gluttony is now
ceased.
I helpless in the rain and then my misery.
I'm not alone for all these are under
the same penalty for the same fold.
And he said no more. Okay. Here
I have to stop a little bit,
uh, the, to tell you what, something
that you already caught. Of course,
what the basic metaphor,
what the basic conceit is in this camp.
And it's the conceit of
the city and the body.
You in classical the classical world,
you are abused to the conceit between,
of their core relationship between the
soul and the city. Uh, but for Dante,
this is a soulless city. The only way to
talk about it is through this imagery.
She's very ancient, very Roman
actually. Uh, the story of, uh, uh,
the city as a corporate, as a
body, as a corporate structure,
the image.
Some of you readers of Shakespeare,
you may remember your collaborators
where Coriolanus makes the same speech
about, uh, the city and the body.
But it really goes back to a historian
of the classical world that Dante
absolutely loves. He's
not the only one. Uh,
all the way a Dustin is
using their name is Livy,
who wrote this famous book about from
about the, from the foundation of Rome,
Roman historian who tells
the history of Roman.
One of the stories he tells
is that, uh, of, uh, uh,
the famous civil war in Rome,
the civil war between patricians
and Plebeians, the Plebeians,
the workers were so tired of
what was happening in the city.
They were doing all the work.
That's the way they complain.
But they had few of the pleasures
coming from living in the city that they
decided to cc'd.
It is a famous session whereby
they go as a kind of schism.
They go on the retreat
on the Aventine hills,
one of the seven hills of Rome and
the patricians, the city's paralyzed.
And you can imagine it's a strike the
patrician send one of the enemy, sorry.
And man by the name of miniatures to
convince the Plebeians to return to the
city and my name use managers to do
this by telling the Plebeians if famous
fable,
which is called,
it's still known as the
stable of miniatures. What
does he tell them? He said,
look, this is really like a
body. When you have a body,
the hence work. Yeah. It seems that
the mouth and joy is, and the savers,
the great pleasures of foods and so on,
it seems that the stomach, it can be full,
but actually whatever they produce
and take in and they ingest,
they redistribute to the bodies, to the
rest of the, about the hands, the feet,
et cetera.
Because the city is like a body.
That's the analogy between the
corporate structure of the city,
the idea that the city is a
corporation and a, which by the way,
we carry on the reminder of this, the how
vital. This is what carried on a dime.
I don't have a dime with me. Uh, but if
you have a dime, you can read. Uh, a blue.
The ooh means says one body out of
many limbs, out of many members,
still an image that we care. It's
still a conceit that we have. Right?
So the idea is,
uh,
that the city is like a body and the
plebeians are convinced and they go back
to,
to back to order.
And then recompose the order of the city.
This is the fundamental structure here,
but I said something else,
which is really is going to,
that's that believe in the
corporate structure of the city. Uh,
can it really hold together
and, Aye. Aye. Aye.
I go on submitting to you that he
no longer believes in this. If you,
when you read the Canto,
uh,
you will see that all the body parts are
literally littering the city there are
mentioned the, the, the
nails, the hands, the heart,
the, the, the beer, the hair, et Cetera,
the mouth and sort of spread all over.
And,
and as if to to imply the impossibilities
of constituting this body parts into
an organic unified, uh, uh, totality. So,
um,
uh,
there's another little issue here that
is being raised and I want to talk about
before the end of, uh, of the hour,
the question of civil war and
whatnot understands by civil war.
It was Dante's political thought.
The reality of his political
thinking is always the civil war.
I come to, let me just give you some
textual evidence and then we'll go on.
I answered him,
chuck that distressed,
so weighs on me that he beats me weep.
But Tommy,
if their cans,
what the citizens of the divided city,
this is not Florence shall come to
and whether any is there is just,
and tell me the cost of such discord
sailing it if an amazing image discord
because it's a musical metaphor.
Our cord, this discord,
but it comes from,
it makes the heart,
that's where the word comes from.
This scored makes the heart,
the place,
the receptacle where all the MVR,
all this jealousness that
destroyed the city, uh, are,
are placed, are located.
And he said to me,
after long strides there shall come to
blood and the party of the rustic shall
drive out the other with much offense.
Then by force of one who is [inaudible],
meaning the pope,
that part is destined to fall.
This is the world's Gibbons
within which the city is divided to
four within three years and the other to
prevail long holding his head high and
keeping the fat first and the grievers
burdens for all the tears and shame
to men are just, they're not heated.
Their pride,
envy and Alvarez,
these are the courses are the sparks.
He calls them.
These are the causes that have
set this hearts on fire here.
He made an end of his grievers, uh, uh,
words and then Dante goes on, uh, uh,
literally evoking a
street scene in Florence.
He goes on asking about some
other characters with the city.
I would still learn from the,
and I begged the to grant me further
speech Farinata he mentioned about whom we
shall see next Thursday in Canto turn
of and the guy your main of such worth
Yacko boosty culture, Rigo Mosca
and the rest whose minds will say,
Tom will doing,
tell me where they are and giving me
knowledge of them for impressed with a
great desire to know where
they share in heaven,
sweetness or the bitterness of hair.
I would like to point out to
you the presence of this, uh,
of the language of gluttony
throughout sweetness, bitterness,
pleasantness, unpleasantness, uh,
this really runs through the candles
that Canto it gives it an end links
together,
gluttony and the politics.
It's the body can the body metaphor,
but also these other experiences.
But what is happening here is he asks
as Dante ass about this other famous for
it, his main of such worth, he says,
what are they? They achieved so much,
were so set on well doing in the city
and the the English cannot quite render
the ambiguity of the Italian and
beautiful Italian is Ben Factory,
which is really very difficult to
translate those you don't know if it means
doing well or doing good and that,
that impossibilities of deciding what
the sentence really means is exactly.
Uh, what Dante is traumatizing here is
dramatizing is the distance between human
perspective humor,
the judgments that we make as human
beings and the divine judgment on their
dealings and doings of these famous
people that the discrepancy between them
here on earth who may judge one way,
then the real,
the reality of the worth and
value of this other people. Uh,
that can be different. So we
are are, we are talking about,
he's talking about their mom. The black
soul. Say they're further down in, in,
in the fire and different faults
weigh them down to the depth where
extraordinary metaphor,
that weight, weight,
that burden of sin,
but it's really an image
that goes back the gravity.
The question of gravity,
this is we speak of civic gravity,
but here it's a different kind of gravity.
It's an idea of um,
it's an old idea when you want to talk
about the weight that we carry within us,
the gravity we have within
us that gravity is love.
The way of deciding what's the
way of understanding this line?
There's a passage in the confessional
from Augusta where Augustine says that he
wants to exemplify what some people go up.
Other people go down and he says,
it's like the gravity
of objects around us.
Stone. You drop a stone and the stone
goes down out of its own gravity.
I told specific weight and fire he says,
goes up out of its own specific weight.
We are carried.
Whatever I love carries us.
We are.
Our love is our own gravity in the
gravity and whether we go up or down,
it depends according to the
direction of our desires.
Whether we just go back to this is uh,
uh,
it's to give you a sense of all
the residences of this cancer,
but at the heart of it all,
that is the question of civil war two,
wealth and gibberellins between
patricians and Peruvians.
Dentist is the whole of history.
Roman history,
whether he's going to read Virgil or we
read Lucan or he will read the stages,
they're all actually deals not
with Roman history. This great,
great epic [inaudible] reads is
really reading Greek history,
the story of we depose and
the Tok Gleason Polynese.
They view history at from the point
of view of the civil war. Now.
So let me just formulate the question
of a part of the political understanding
Dante has. For those of you who may
have read a little bit of monarch here,
for instance,
which is this treatise about the,
the desirable form of a
Universal Confederation of
states and the one emperor.
That's the grand vision
that Dante has in monarch.
He thinks about that they need that unity
of all states. I kind of the sort of,
we could call it today,
a confederation of States,
very much patterns are all on,
on the Roman,
the Roman Empire, the
idea of there, in fact,
the Roman empire becomes the model
for this kind of unification. Uh,
so that's really what most of us think,
that Dante's political
vision is in effect.
Dante sees history especially as,
and it's kind of inevitable
satanic form of civil war. So,
so harsh can, is he going to be
about the realities of the cities?
You really wonder how can he
go on elaborating a theory
of a constructive theory
of politics?
You see what I'm saying?
Once you are so harsh about
the reality of politics,
then you really wonder how that can one
go around really thinking that politics
can be in necessarily cause unnecessary.
You can explain that it's somehow
useful, that it's feasible. Uh,
where does this idea, what is this
is this understanding of Rome? Um,
come to him.
Dante is not really agree with Virgil
and Dante is not agreed with Virgil's
greatest critic who is
Augustan in the city of God.
For Virgil Rome is the
providential empire,
an empire that can really bring about
unify the whole world are gusted rights
against Virgil and says
no because even Rome,
as I just indicated to
you and the learner,
even Rome is part of
the history of violence.
Dante comes along and puts together
within the divine comedy that question of
Rome and the needed empire and
the question of the civil war,
what do they have in common?
What is that connects them.
Dante's argument is the following you
Virgil are right in believing in the unity
of all mankind,
stoic idea we all live in that
costs more police in the city,
which is the city of the world where we
all find the place and you Augustan or
right in claiming that the
empire is all built and based on
Libido and lust.
You're right,
you're both right and yet you
are both wrong besides me.
Cause you contradict each other and
what Dante says Augustan if there is no
empire,
then we are living in a world
of disorder and lawlessness.
The empire becomes the necessary
remedy to the evils of the civil war.
The civil war is the condition
where my own brother,
my own neighbor can be,
can become my own enemy.
Gaston does not acknowledge
the realities of war to him.
It's just empire and the empire is evil
and will finish with the famous line.
What do I care who governs me,
provided that they don't make me sin.
It's the famous Christian
response to the idea of the evil,
the historical evil of empires.
Let me retreat into myself and
find within myself some kind of of,
uh,
of uh,
comfort and some kite of shelter
and Dante will respond to him.
No,
that's not enough.
Because once you think that you
have retreated into yourself,
then there is the reality of the
civil war that we're reaching to you.
What have been explaining
to you that we stop? Uh,
because I want to talk about something
else before we go 10 to seven.
What I've been trying to explain to you
is that that the movement from 10 to
five to Canto six of inferno,
it's a movement from the internal world
of desires that seemed to be so private
and so personal.
Then I said,
Dan has to go outside of himself to test
to find out what the authenticity is of
what he has found out in Canto five
and 10, two, six, the political canter.
We'll tell them that there is no such
a comfort zone of one's home in a world
that in the world is necessary necessarily
part of the outside world and outside
world will encroach upon. It, will
end once own in the, in the world.
Uh, the terms will this kind of movement
between the inner and the outer, uh,
really,
uh,
Virgil and the Guston virtual with the
idea of the fence of the empire Augustan
with his undermining of the notion
of the necessity of the empire.
Dante,
we'll go on a harmonizing the two visions.
So he will endorse the idea of the
empire and aware that that's the only
possible best response to
the tragedy of civil wars.
Let me say just a few things
about canto seven. Uh,
the, the, and then I'll give you a chance
to ask. Sometimes they'll should be two,
three minutes for questions
or came to seven. Um, uh,
also is a candle that can
be read symmetrically with
the other Canto seven of
the divine comedy purgatorial
seven but Justice Canto six, I,
I neglected to mention it but uh,
Canto six of impairment is about the
city and politics can two six approval
story about the nation can two,
six of paradise about the empire.
So they're really connected in the same
thing with Qantas ever. This is the only,
can't wear that to the smoke.
Individualize sinners.
He meets avaricious.
There are issues and the protocols and
there are sort of taken in a kind of,
they have no,
there's no individual figuration for them.
It is as if this became
a kind of an anonymous,
therefore more collective kind of problem.
Other issues and probiotics,
which he represents in terms of the
counter movement of Sealer and Caribbean.
This. And here we have the great
figuration of fortune. You remember, Eh,
as I call her,
the Vanna white of the time that
the lady who is a wheel of fortune,
uh, turning back blindfolded. And,
and, and let me say something about,
about this figuration as is
Dante describes it as a, uh, uh,
you know, what, what is it a,
it's a great an idea that I,
um,
uh,
what is it about the avaricious and
the prodigals who could turn around?
So a one against the
other, uh, how can this be?
How can this be possible? Uh, uh, what is,
why are we so attached to,
to the things of the world?
And then Dante goes on explaining a,
on a canto seven lines eight
and following, uh, he will say,
ah,
he ordained for he meaning God or
then for worldly splendors a general
ministered and guide who shouldn't do
time change vein well from race to race
and from one to another blood beyond
the prevention of human, which,
so that one race rules. And another
language is accord the best sentence. Ah,
she foresees judges and maintains a
kingdom as the other heavily powers do
theirs.
How changes have no respite
necessity makes a swift so fast.
Men come to take the turn,
et cetera are,
this is he who is so reviled,
meaning fortune by the very main
that should give her praise,
laying on her wrong who blame and
ill repute. But she's blessed.
It does not hear it happy with the other
primal creatures. She turns us fear.
Every Joyce's in her, bless.
It's fortunate that wheel,
but it's a figuration that in
many ways it needs some, uh,
some explaining.
How can Nantais believe
in goddess for tuna?
How can he go on talking
about this Pagan Deity,
which is a roamer deity lady
luck or how is he doing this?
How can that, do you see how, how he,
he lives in a world of a providential
reality, whether it's an ink well, uh,
and he does say that fortunate is an
intelligence of God. So they are not,
the Dosha is blindfolded.
That is also kind of, uh, um,
there are some criteria.
There is an intelligence,
there is a will and the meditation
behind it. What it means is that a,
what is up with inevitably
turned down to go down.
This is an endless rotation or fortune
and certain way when you are down,
uh,
you only the only it's the head,
best time to be at because you
don't have to, you can only go up.
We are always though on these
precarious repost on this, uh,
on the curve. We are never quite
a stable in our own achievements.
How can that relate this a try id or
fortune to the providential scheme,
uh, that he, he uh,
he regulates and shapes his own vision.
And what I would have to tell you
is that the, uh, the two things,
the first thing is that
there's UC canter's haven't
begins with an illusion to
the great war in heaven.
The angels,
the primal struggle that that
disrupted the order of the cosmos.
In other words,
fortune is for him the divinity
that rules over the world,
the sub lunar,
a world of generation and corruption.
This to say she is a minister within the,
the,
the world of the fall for steak.
Uh,
so there there's still a foreign world
and that's how perception of all the
changes that take place.
And the other thing is that Dante is
intimating that the only way to conquer
fortune is to really give up a,
it says kind of mystical idea. Uh,
Mr [inaudible] has a spiritual idea,
give up the attachment to the things
of this world. So let's stop here,
uh,
with uh,
with a brief summary of Canto seven items.
See if there are questions
about some of the,
a weighty issues that I
raised in Canto five and six.
And there isn't much more that we can say,
but let me see if you want to
cost ask questions and maybe I can
clarify things that were left in the
background.
Please.
I'm going to cancel five.
The narrative of Francesco Palo.
What is the significance that
Francesca is doing all the talking?
What is the question
is very good question.
What is the significance of Francesca
is doing all the talking and uh,
and not Paolo. I guess I take the, the,
the significance is that this is to me
is that this is a canto or where Dante
understands some of the elements that
he had put forth in the Vita Nuova.
You remember where we discuss the Viton
Nuova and there I indicated that the
great poem, women who have
intellect of love, where the, uh,
he discovers that they are
the interlocutors about love,
not only the interlocutors about love
there also those are the privileges
interlocutors because they know how
to combine because they understand the
unnecessary interdependence
of intellect and love.
They are not two separate entities.
They are not two separate, uh,
aspects. And therefore, uh,
now he has Francesca as a woman who
can become indeed his own interlocutor.
That's one aspect.
The other one is that medieval romances
had made this extraordinary discovery
and I think is the most revolutionary
change that has taken place in the,
in the consciousness of, in the, in the
imagination of the, in the Western world,
in modern times. That is to say
before it became a sociological issue,
before it becomes a philosophical problem,
the dignity and worth of the woman was
already retrieved and vindicated by
romances.
It's there,
but the woman becomes either the figure
in charge or the partner or friend of a,
of the man.
Does that answer your question
by the way?
The answer was yes.
That could not be picked
up by the the video. Ah,
other questions?
I'm okay.
Thank you.
We'll see you next time with
Kantar nine 10 and 11 I guess.